[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing verit serum
an incredibly powerful and I feel
underutilized potion that forces
individuals to reveal the truth it is
verit serum a truth potion so powerful
that three drops would have you spilling
your innermost secrets for this entire
class to hear now the use of this potion
is controlled by very strict Ministry
guidelines but unless you watch your
step you might just find that my hand
slips right over your evening pumpkin
juice and then Potter then we'll find
out whether you've been in my office or
not besides maybe Felix felices poly
juice potion and a Morena I feel as
though verit serum AKA truth serum is
one of the most powerful potions in the
entire Wizarding World and given this
fact I can't help but notice that it's
ludicrously underutilized at least in
the series in fact the list of times
that it's actually used in the story is
exceedingly short these moments include
giving it to B Crouch Jr after
discovering that he was disguised as D
Professor M Moody and Rita ska using it
on batilda backshot while interviewing
her for Alber Dumbledore's biography
there were of course other times that it
was mentioned like when Dolores Umbridge
used a fake potion made by Snape on
Harry Potter that he only pretended to
drink but on the whole it's not even
talked about that much and I feel like
it could bring about a whole lot of
clarity especially in the context of
convicting criminals in the death eer
trials for example Eagle karov was
pardoned by the wizen gamut after giving
up the names of some of his
co-conspirators why not just feed him
truth serum in today's video we'll be
discussing why verit serum isn't more
actively used by the ministry of magic
we'll also be discussing use cases from
the story in which verit serum could
have proven to be extremely useful
potentially saving lives in the process
let's dive in legal limitations while
the lack of Truth serum's use outside of
the Wizarding courts makes considerably
less sense it's important to remember
that there are significant legal
limitations when it comes to its
admissibility as evidence in Wizarding
courts unlike muggle legal systems The
Wizarding World lacks explicit laws and
regulations specifically addressing the
use of Truth potions like serum the
absence of clear guidelines regarding
its admissibility creates uncertainty
and raises concerns about the
reliability of using verit serum as
evidence additionally proving the
authenticity and reliability of verit
serum induced statements can be
challenging the skepticism may arise
regarding the accuracy of the extracted
information as there is no foolproof
method to determine if someone's
responses are influenced solely by
veritos serum or if they are crafting
elaborate lies mixed with some truths
furthermore in the pursuit of Justice it
is vital to preserve the legal rights of
the accused the usage of verium can
potentially infringe upon these rights
including the right to a fair trial and
the presumption of innocence until
proven guilty forcing individuals to
divulge their secrets or compel them to
answer specific questions removes their
agency and undermines the principle of
fair and impartial judgment it's
entirely possible that the use of verit
serum may lead to coerced confessions
violating the rights of individuals who
may be innocent coercion can occur
through manipulation intimidation or
other forms of duress creating a
situation where the truth may be
revealed but Justice is not necessarily
served the limitations surrounding verit
serum in The Wizarding World actually
Bear striking similarities to the usage
of lie detectors or polygraph tests in
Muckle courts lie detectors also aim to
ascertain the truthfulness of
individuals by analyzing physiological
responses such as changes in heart rate
blood pressure and skin
conductivity however lie detectors are
not widely accepted as admissible
evidence in muggle courts and their
usage is highly controversial yes truth
serum is more powerful and possibly
slightly more reliable but it still has
its issues one parallel between verit
serum and lie detectors lies in their
lack of scientific reliability while
verit Serum is a powerful potion that
compels individuals to speak the truth
there is no foolproof method to
determine if the information extracted
is entirely accurate or influenced by
external factors similarly Li detectors
have been criticized for their inability
to definitively detect deception as the
physiological respon is monitored can be
influenced by a variety of factors
including anxiety stress or personal
beliefs both vertiserum and lie
detectors face admissibility challenges
in their respective legal systems there
is a need for Clear legal guidelines and
standardization on the use of these
truth revealing methods which currently
lack comprehensive regulation in both
muggle and Wizarding legal systems
practical challenges while vertis serms
truth inducing properties make it an
enticing tool for uncovering the truth
there are several other practical
factors to consider when analyzing its
lack of widespread usage within the
wisting world the first is dosage and
administration verit serum requires
precise dosage and admin rtion to ensure
its Effectiveness without causing harm
to the subject administering the potion
incorrectly or in excessive amounts can
have adverse effects on the individual's
physical and mental well-being this
necessitates trained and skilled
Professionals for the proper use of
veritos serum adding an additional layer
of complexity to its implementation the
next is resistance it's entirely
possible that some individuals may
develop resistance to the effects of
veritos serum thereby limiting its
reliability some Wizards and witches
with exceptional mental fortitude or
training May possess the ability to
resist the potions truth inducing
effects rendering it ineffective against
them I would imagine that a trained oans
who has mastered their own mind and
thoughts may be able to resist the
potion's effects another large aspect
that I've overlooked so far is that
there is actually a counter potion or
antidote to veritaserum rendering the
influence of veritaserum ineffective
such a potion was known to be carried by
Horus slug horn you don't need me you
could use legilimency or verit serum
Professor slug horn is an extremely able
wizard who will be expecting both he is
much more accomplished at oceny than
poor Morphin gaunt and I would be
astonished if he has not carried an
antidote to verit to Serum with him ever
since I coerced him into giving me this
travesty of a
recollection lastly missuse must be
considered its potent truth inducing
effects make it a target for those
seeking to exploit it for personal gain
or manipulate others and it's this
potential for abuse that reinforces the
need for strict regulation and control
over the distribution and use of
veritaserum all of the challenges above
adequately highlight the complexities
involved in utilizing veritus serum
effectively and responsibly and thus
contribute to the ministry of Magic's
limited Reliance on this truth inducing
potion in various practical scenarios
I'm sure there are also a whole bunch
more that I haven't considered
potential use cases in the series
besides the overarching topic of why the
ministry doesn't employ verit serum in
Trials I also want to take a look at all
of the controversial times where
something like truth serum could have
perceived importance taking a closer
look at why or why not truth serum may
have worked Voldemort's return in the
Harry Potter story Harry is given a
number of nicknames good and bad but
among the worst was The Boy Who Lies a
nickname he earned after shouting from
the rooftop tops at voldemor had indeed
returned however no one listened to poor
Harry the main reason being fear
particularly on the part of Cornelius
fudge in order to cope many found it
easier to deny or ignore the reality of
Voldemort's return out of fear for their
own safety or a desire to maintain a
sense of normaly Minister for magic
Cornelius fudge was one of these people
and he had no hesitation in publicly
demonizing Harry and Publishing all
sorts of propaganda in the daily profit
to discredit him one could argue that
this would have been a perfect time to
use verit to serum effectively
eliminating any doubt in the minds of
the ministry however here's the thing I
don't think it would have mattered the
evidence pointing towards Voldemort's
return was already pretty much
incontrovertible and fudge still chose
to ignore it he was simply too
entrenched in fear to accept Voldemort's
return as a possibility the only thing
that would work to convince fudge
otherwise would be to stare Voldemort
straight in the face which he later did
clearing Sirius Black's name one of the
big tragedies in the Harry Potter story
was Sirius Black's wrongful imprisonment
in aaban forcing him to endure an
unimaginable 12 years in the torturous
Island Fortress he was ultimately
charged with murdering Peter Petru 12
innocent Muggles and for serving Lord
Voldemort on the surface it feels like
veritus serum could have been easily
used to prove sirious Black's innocence
in this instance he could have explained
that Pettigrew was alive and that he had
framed Sirius the only problem was all
of the evidence was acting against him
he also never acted like an innocent man
upon being first discovered Sirius was
found hysterically laughing we now know
that this was due to his inability to
process the grief he was overcome by but
outwardly gave Ministry officials and
others the impression that he was just
insane and happy with what he had just
done a crater in the middle of the
street so deep it had cracked the sewer
below bodies everywhere Muggles
screaming and black standing there
laughing with what was left to pettigru
in front of him Sirus also never defends
his innocence and once again this is
likely due to the fact that he was still
processing the atrocities that had
occurred right in front of him his best
friends had just been murdered and he
was being blamed so he clearly had a lot
to process furthermore dumore himself
did not believe sirius's innocence there
is not a shred of proof to support black
story except your word and the word of
two 13-year-old Wizards will not
convince anybody a Street full of
eyewitnesses swore they saw serious
murder pettigru I myself gave evidence
to the ministry that Sirius had been The
Potter's Secret Keeper in this instance
the seemingly undeniable evidence
against Sirius negated any need for a
proper trial let alone the use of verit
serum questioning snap's loyalty one use
case that I couldn't help but consider
pertains to Snape and Voldemort for the
duration of the story SN n was a double
agent and both sides felt they had an
ally however given his history it's
surprising that neither side would think
to enlist verit serum it just feels like
the obvious way to ensure that someone
is being truthful with you especially
when they flip-flopped between
allegiances in the past Voldemort should
have used it on Snape here's the thing
though I don't think that Voldemort
would ever use something like verit
serum because of his pride Voldemort
thought himself the most powerful dark
wizard in all the land which came with
considerable pride and arrogance he was
a master legilimens a master of the mind
and to him it may not have even been a
consideration that someone could elude
his suspicions in this respect his
arrogance may have once again gotten the
better of him alternatively Voldemort
may have recognized that veritaserum
would be ineffective on Snape a master
oans he also had no real reason to
question him rowlings answer in addition
to all of the information presented
above I've also decided to include an
excerpt from an interview with JK
Rowling where she discusses the
properties of veritaserum and why it
wasn't used more verit serum plays a big
part in finding out the truth from Madi
moody in book four why then is it not
used for example in the trials mentioned
in the same book it would be much easier
in solving problems like whether sirious
black was guilty or not veritus serum
works best upon the unsuspecting the
vulnerable and those insufficiently
skilled in one way or another to protect
the eles against it Barty Crouch had
been attacked before the potion was
given to him and was still very groggy
otherwise he could have employed a range
of measures against the potion he might
have sealed his own throat and faked a
declaration of Innocence transform the
potion into something else before it
touched his lips or employed emancy
against its effects in other words just
like every other kind of magic within
the books verac Serum is not infallible
as some Wizards can prevent themselves
being affected and others cannot it is
an unfair and unreliable tool to use at
a trial Sirius might have volunteered to
take the potion had he been given the
chance but he was never offered it Mr
Crouch senior power mad and increasingly
unjust in the way he was treating
suspects threw him into asan on the
admittedly rather convincing testimony
of many eyewitnesses the sad fact is
that even if Sirius had told the truth
under the influence of the potion Mr
Crouch could still have insisted that he
was using trickery to render himself
immune to it and there you have it every
explanation for why verit Serum is not
heavily utilized in The Wizarding World
as always if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to
live